I try to be over prepared in some sense
so I mean I believe that if you're going
to give a 20-minute lecture you should
have an hour of material at hand because
that way you have an opportunity to sort
of move spontaneously through the
material but generally what I do now
because I have a lot of material usually
before a lecture I'll sit down for 20
minutes with my eyes closed and I figure
out what the central topic is so there's
always a question what's the question
I'm trying to address in this lecture
and then I'll figure out a pathway
through it it's like okay well here's
the argument here's point one here's
point two here's point three and there's
possible branches off those and then
with each point I usually have a
collection of stories so you lay out the
story and then you can use the responses
of the audience to guide how you're
going to walk through it practice gives
you ultimate Freedom the more you
practice the better you get at something
the more skilled you are at it the more
information you have the more it
actually allows you to play more have
more fun be more flexible and have
ultimately more freedom this is
something I struggled with a lot in the
early days of my speaking career I was
asked to speak at a bunch of events and
this is what 20 years ago I guess I've
I've had as a speaking career now and I
used to be so worried about
disappointing people that I would
memorize my entire speech I would
practice and practice and practice and
practice and practice and just memorize
my speech to the point where
word for word it would be the exact same
thing every time and I thought that was
good I thought that's what you're
supposed to do obviously yes practice
makes perfect keep going keep practicing
keep doing it and what ended up
happening was yes I delivered the same
speech each time but I think the worst
thing you can do as a speaker is just
give the exact same speech every time
we did a session of movement makers
around the signature talk it was one of
the most voted topics was how do I give
my signature talk and I think having one
signature talk is actually not great I
think you should be able to
be able to speak to the audience every
time your job if you're a speaker is to
give your audience a fantastic
experience and so it's knowing who's in
the audience don't assume it's the same
people every single time
right so you have to be able to know so
much about your subject that then you
can have your framework that you operate
in but then give a lot more value to
People by making a custom to them
so now whenever I'm doing a speaking gig
I'm always asking okay tell me about the
audience tell me who's here tell me why
people are setting it up what are people
here for both in terms of the
information they're hoping to get as
well as their background and their
interests and their concerns and what
they struggle with and of course there's
genuine human struggles that everybody
goes through but why are people here at
this conference and so here's my process
right now when I'm doing a a speech or
talk
they're gonna have me coming they're
going to talk about believer
entrepreneurship or YouTube there's
gonna be some set themes you're not
having me come to talk about my apple
strudel recipe
because I don't have one right I'm
coming to talk about things that are
inside my domain perfect
and I could easily just get up on stage
and talk
but I want to know who's in the audience
so before going I'll ask them tell me
about the people who are going to be
here and then I'll frame my speech
around a couple of key ideas that I
think would be valuable to that audience
still sitting within kind of the my
usual domain perfect
I'll practice it I'll practice giving a
speech I'll practice the points at home
I'll practice I'll practice talking to
my dog I'll practice on the airplane on
the way over I'll practice to kind of
get a sense of the stories that I want
to tell that I think will be the right
fit
but then the day before and the day of I
like to be there a little early to to
talk to people to one makes me feel a
little more comfortable
um being able to connect to people in
the audience so it's not just
people I don't know but I've had a few
conversations with people but two
in feeling the vibe out of the event
I'll often end up switching up part of
my talk again to make it as customizable
as possible to the people I'm talking to
and this isn't just a speaking thing
guys this is any interaction you're
doing you're trying to sell your product
trying to sell your service you're on a
call with somebody who could use your
product service hire you as a coach
Etc you have to customize your pitch
customize your talk for them not just
give the same thing every single time
you're talking to somebody you have to
know what makes them tick know why
they're talking to you what their their
deep desires and fears are and address
those things so that you can close the
sale right it's the same thing I'm just
giving an example through speaking
has been willing to deviate
from your talk
to actually give more value
and I think again the worst thing you
can do as a speaker is just give get
unsafe you can get the same talk every
single time
that's what I used to think was the way
to go but this is actually a lot more
valuable
because you can inspire people but one
it becomes boring for you to get up and
just do the same thing over and over and
over again and two if you can customize
it to actually address the thing that
they're specifically concerned about
you're gonna have a bigger impact why
are you there you're there to touch
people you're there to move people to a
positive direction right
again whether you're whether you're
speaking or you're just talking to
somebody on the phone a potential client
why are you working with them yes
they're going to pay you but why you
want them to get a result you want them
to move you want them to make a change
you want to solve a problem for them and
so the more you can actually connect to
what they're struggling with the easier
it is for you to
to close the sale and have the impact
that you're trying to have so it's a lot
more fun it's a lot more impactful a lot
more meaningful and so that's my usual
process now why are people here
I'll prepare a version of my speech to
address those people and then it always
changes up the day of because I met
somebody in the lobby who inspired me or
I met somebody on the airplane the day
before who shifted my thinking a little
bit and gives me an extra story to tell
and when you're so prepared and you know
your stuff so much it's easy to add
those things in
when you don't really know
you're kind of all over the place
so it's being overly prepared and then
the day of being willing to be flexible
it's not like rigidity of practice and
practice and practice and knowing what
you're doing so much that allows you to
play when you show up it's the you know
going to sports you practice your free
throws so much your practice your
penalty shot so much you practice you
practice so much that allows you to be a
lot more flexible to play when it comes
to game time let me share another quick
example from the opposite side where I
was interviewing somebody so instead of
being the person on stage speaking I'm
interviewing somebody and I recently had
Tony Robbins on the channel and it was
the third time it came on the channel
the first two interviews we did had
three million views on them combined
which is amazing and he's coming back
for the third time talk about his new
book and I'm always nervous before a big
interview and this is probably the least
nervous I've been because it's the third
time on but I was still nervous going in
and so I'm preparing I'm preparing and
preparing and preparing I'm trying to
find a thread that I care about I don't
want to just ask the same questions
everybody else has ass I don't to just
use the questions that his PR agency
sent over because he's going to answer
those questions on every other show I
want it to be different and unique and
fun and special and so I prepared I know
I've got
a half an hour with him I know he likes
to go long in his stories so you don't
get that many questions in so I need to
I need to really be careful of what I'm
going to say and make this time count
it'd be easy just to show up and ask
okay why did you write this book what
does it mean to you what do you hope
people get from it what was your
favorite part about it and then then
half an hour is done and you haven't
really asked anything super meaningful
so I'm preparing
and I wrote down on a notepad file that
I had opened when I was talking to him
you know four questions five questions
that I wanted to ask and I practiced how
I would ask them to practice you know
what what I was going to say
and then I practiced it so much that
come game time come show time here we go
Tony's coming on let's let's do our
one-on-one
I was able to actually be present and
listen to what I was saying and and play
ball with him right to to throw and
catch with him instead of just going to
the questions when you haven't prepared
and you're really insecure you just go
to the questions you just go okay here's
what I said okay here and just ask the
question we're the best interviews are
when you can throw and catch right where
they say something and you take that a
little bit deeper as opposed to just
moving on to the next question because
I've watched a lot of interviews and in
the work that I do and one of the things
that I find most frustrating is the
person says something amazing and you
want them to it's like okay ask a
follow-up question and instead of asking
a follow-up question then just go to the
next question
because the interviewer it was never
even listening to what the interviewee
was saying they're just so worried about
getting the next question in that that's
that's all they're thinking about and so
like okay great and then tell me about
this next question without going deeper
into the conversation so I didn't want
to be that kind of interviewer even I
get it because you're nervous
you're not fully prepared you're worried
about the questions
so one example with Tony he was talking
about a recent Health scare that he had
and that his career be over
the doctor said your career is over
and in my head I was thinking about some
of the other stuff I knew about Tony
Robbins and so I asked him how many
times have you been told that your
career is over
it was off script right it wasn't
something his team prepared it wasn't
something Tony's maybe been asked I
asked how many times have you been told
that your career's been over because I
remember uh you know he had this
tumor that made him grow crazy quickly
and and people said his life would be
over remember he burned out his voice
box and his doctors told him he'd never
speak on stage again and now this injury
that happened to him he wasn't gonna be
able to go into his event so he's been
told consistently that his career would
be over
and yet he still gets up and he finds a
way and he does it right one of the
things that we love about his ability to
follow through and stay consistent and
so in the over preparation and knowing
his story and also knowing that I had
questions to fall back on in case
there was a lull on the conversation it
allows the play it allows the freedom it
allows you to adjust the situation which
then creates a much better experience so
whether you're speaking whether you're
interviewing whether you're coaching
whether you're mentoring whether you're
on a sales call
you need to know your script you need to
know what you're going to say you need
to understand your customer and who
you're talking to you need to know all
that and over prepare
but then understand that the greatest
asset that you have is not in rehearsing
again the script is that you have the
ability to be free now
that you can play because you've done
all the drills and now you need to have
the back and forth it's it's throwing
and catching I'm going to throw the ball
to you you're going to catch it you're
gonna throw the ball back to me it's not
just throwing where a lot of times the
biggest mistake is that you're just
throwing you're just throwing another
one and another one and here's my other
line here's my next question here's my
next pitch throw throw throw throw
and the person I'd be saying but there's
no receiving and them throwing the ball
back to you that's the best part in any
interaction if you have a goal to get
them to move forward to make a change in
their life just to sign you up to hire
you to work with you so you can make
that impact that you're trying to make
there has to be that back and forth and
the more prepared you are the easier it
is to then have the freedom to play also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
it is my firm belief that each of us
have a responsibility to set the world
right in the manner that we are able to
and that that is a
fundamental
that's a fundamental import I really
believe in some sense it's of cosmic
import
in the same way that Consciousness
itself is of cosmic import and
Consciousness reflects being itself you
arrived in the book there is no faith
and no courage and no sacrifice in doing
what is expedient
what do you say to those viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and are locked
into their careers because they are too
afraid to take risks and pursue
something meaningful well the first
thing I would say is well you should be
afraid of taking risks and pursuing
something meaningful
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are if it's making you
miserable it's like the first thing you
want to do is dispense with the idea
that you get to have any any permanent
security outside of your ability to
contend and adapt it's the same issue
with children it's like you're paying a
price by sitting there being miserable
and you might say well the devil I know
is better than the one I don't it's like
don't be so sure of that the clock is
ticking yeah and if you're miserable in
your job now and you change nothing in
five years you'll be much more miserable
and you'll be a lot older but this isn't
it a luxury to pursue what is Meaningful
our viewers have mortgages they have
children they have payments and Loans
it's a luxury to pursue because we lack
the resources well I don't think I don't
remember now I'm not talking about what
makes you happy
it's a luxury to pursue what makes you
happy it's a moral obligation to pursue
what you find meaningful and that
doesn't mean it's easy it might require
sacrifice if you need to change your job
too let's say you have a family and and
children and a mortgage you have
responsibilities
you've already picked up those
responsibilities you don't just get to
walk away scot-free and say well I don't
like my job I quit that's no strategy
but what you might have to do is you
think well this job is killing my soul
all right so what do I have to do about
that well I have to look for another job
well no one wants to hire me it's like
okay maybe you need to educate yourself
more maybe you need to update your your
curriculum Vita your resume maybe you
need to overcome your fear of being
interviewed maybe you need to sharpen
your social skills like you you have to
think about these things strategically
if you're going to switch careers you
have to do it like an intelligent
responsible person that might take you a
couple of years of of of effort I've
dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and Consulting practice and we
set a goal we develop a vision and work
towards it and it things inevitably get
better for people so it's not a luxury
it's it's difficult it's a moral
responsibility and it isn't happiness
it's it's not the pursuit isn't for how
well that isn't how it is it's like
we're built for struggle us human beings
not after
um the bubbles of bliss that Dostoevsky
described in in Notes from Underground
were built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want to challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because a
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and Fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so and I'm not
saying that in a naive way I know
perfectly well what happens to people
you know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later you're dead and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point but that's not the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and contend and you
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do compare yourself to who
you were yesterday and not to who
someone else is today
uh because if you're comparing yourself
to someone else I mean first of all you
don't know very much about the life of
the person you're comparing yourself to
you don't know and it know it across all
of its dimensions and second people are
very different and so comparing yourself
to someone else
it's it's kind of useful I guess when
you're young but as you get older and
more singular and more particular it
becomes increasingly less useful better
to compare yourself to a previous
version of yourself and work for
improvement in that way life is
difficult and you cannot protect your
children
what you can do is prepare them and you
can prepare them to be strong and
courageous and truthful and resilient
and reciprocal in their interactions
with other people and that means you
equip them for what life will be which
is at minimum a series of difficult
challenges and and often more than that
because of course people go through very
difficult times in their lives and
a resilient person is capable of
standing up to things in the face of
fear and moving forward voluntarily
convinced of their own competence and
ability to Prevail and so the primary
your primary goal as a parent apart from
facilitating your child's social
desirability which is a major
obligation on your part is to encourage
your children and to and I mean that
literally to instill in them a sense of
courage in the face of the difficulties
of life and not to protect them from
that we don't even want to be protected
from those difficulties because a major
part of life and its meaning is the
the challenge that comes with
confronting difficulties I said with
Bill c-16 that I wouldn't speak the
language of the radical leftists because
I don't think that that language should
Define the game but let's say it does so
here's the game
the world is a battleground of groups
and the they're battling for power
that's it that's the game and some of
them win and they oppress those who
don't win so that's how we're going to
view the world
okay now the leftists say okay well
here's the oppressed people the
oppressors
the patriarchy type patriarchal types
they should be ashamed of themselves and
give up some power
the right Wingers the radical
right-wingers look at that and they say
oh I see so the game is ethnic identity
is it it's it's identity politics okay
we're white males
we're not going to lose
that's the right-wing version of
identity politics it's like screw you
if we're going to divide into groups if
we're going to divide into tribes
and I'm in my tribe I'm not going to get
all guilty and lose
I'm gonna get all cruel and win
and that's like then you think well
there's people in the middle they're
kind of looking back and forth which
side of the identity politics Spectrum
am I going to fall in do I want to go
with uh do I want to go do I want to be
driven primarily by compassion and am I
going to accept guilt for my historical
privilege so that's one possibility and
then I'm the oppressor I'm the member of
the oppressor group or am I going to say
oh no to hell with that I'm just going
to play the wind well then I'm going to
go to the right
it's like well my sense is how about we
don't play either of those games and the
reason we shouldn't play them is well
the Soviets played the left-wing game
and like killed who knows how many tens
of millions of people you can't even
count it accurately the estimates range
from 20 to 100 million those are pretty
big error bars and the maoists may be a
hundred million certainly 60 million so
okay that didn't work out so well then
there's the Nazis like they played
ethnic identity politics and racial
superiority it's like what do we want to
play that game
see what I've been trying to do really
what I've been trying to do for the last
30 years is say look
there's heavy Temptations to play those
sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together
stand up in the world make something of
yourself stay away from the ideological
oversimplifications
set your house in order that's rule six
in the in the in this book so I have a
book rule in there says set your house
in perfect order before you criticize
the world and it's a very dark chapter
about the motivations of the Columbine
High School killers and this other guy
named Carl panzram who is a serial
rapist and arsonist and murderer and
these he wrote an autobiography and the
Columbine kids also wrote about why they
did what they did they're resentful to
the core bitter bitter resentful
terrible
and
well I'm suggesting that people stay
away from that resentment resentfulness
and bitterness even though life is hard
and and there's malevolence in the world
it's like yeah you can you can tell a
story where everyone's a victim because
we all die we all get sick
you know and and and things happen to us
that are
bitter and terrible betrayal deceit lies
like people hurt us on purpose you know
so it's not just the tragedy of life
it's malevolence as well it's everyone's
a victim you can tell that story the
problem is if you tell that story and
you start to act it out you make all of
that worse that's the problem and it's
so this is why partly I got attracted to
Christian imagery at least in part
um because there's an idea in
Christianity that you should pick up
your God cross and like walk up the hill
and that's
dramatically that's correct
that's the right answer it's like
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust so what are you going to do about
it accept it voluntarily and try to
transform as a consequence
that's the right answer it's the right
answer because the rest of it is
tribalism and we're we're too
technologically possible the baboon here
who's supposed to be basically just a
fool when the story was first written he
turned into what's essentially a shaman
across time and so he represents the
self from the union perspective now the
self is everything you could be across
time so imagine that there's you and
there's the potential inside you
whatever that is you know and potential
is an interesting idea because it's
represents something that isn't yet real
yet we act like it's real because people
will say to you you should live up to
your potential and that potential is
partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
Central and that would be say like The
Rock in The Pride Rock in The Lion King
because you take yourself out of your
Dopey little village and that's just a
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you and dual
familial and social harmony
that's what I want people say that to me
and you know I don't think it's exactly
right there's there's a line in the Old
Testament the fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom and I think it's
more like that it's not that I'm
courageous it's that I'm afraid of the
right things
so when I made my videos it wasn't like
that didn't make me nervous
but I was less nervous about going back
to bed and not saying what I had to say
than I was about making the videos
because I know where this is going
I don't want to go there and so
it's it's not so much courage it's that
it's a matter of I it's it's it's less
risky to say something
than to remain silent when you know
there's something to be said I know that
to be the case and so lots of times in
life it's like there's no pathway
forward that's going to Shield you from
risk you get to pick this risk or you
get to pick this risk and I think I
picked the Lesser risk and that might be
wise but I'm not so sure it's courageous
you don't tell your kid here is an
impossible thing why don't you go out
and fail you say here's something worth
going after here's a step you could take
that would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
call that within a time frame within
some time frame that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's a that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named vygotsky he was
a Russian developmental psychologist and
a smart one it's where the idea of the
Zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone you're expanding
your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay I need to set a
goal but I need to set a goal that
someone as stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it right and then you go
then you've got it perfectly because
it's not so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well I couldn't do well because that
happens to people happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well I
set a goal and I didn't attain it so I'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you wanted to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
that's why I'm being a victim yeah which
isn't helpful you're still going to be a
victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so you know because life is
this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem not only do you
have to move from point A to B in life
but point A is often a very difficult
place to be because we're fragile and
bounded and mortal and limited and
because we know that and so one of the
implications of that as many great
religious Traditions are at pains to
illustrate or demonstrate or Proclaim is
that life is essentially suffering and I
believe that to be a fundamental truth
but
but perhaps not the most fundamental
truth because I think the most
fundamental truth is that despite the
fact that life is suffering people can
transcend that and partly the way they
transcend that is by pursuing things of
value and so that if there is no value
proposition at hand then you have no
meaning to justify the difficult
conditions of your life and that's
brutally difficult for people you know
Nietzsche said he who has a why can bear
any how
and you see and I've certainly seen this
as a clinical practitioner that people
who have no purpose in their life
are embittered by the difficulties of
their life and they become first bitter
and then resentful and then revengeful
and then cruel and there's plenty of
places to go past cruel that's just
where you start if you're really on a
downhill path the more radical the
necessary change the more pain that
accompanies it like the more opportunity
as well
but and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully and so it's not surprising
that people shrink away from learning we
learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that like the
things that really that you really
learned in life it's like it was no joy
man like it took you out and so the fact
that people flee from that is hardly
surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better the better ideas to
eat a little Poison every day so that
you don't have to overdose in a month
it's something like that
and it is the case that I think because
you don't you aren't forced first of all
you don't learn unless you're forced to
learn I know there's alternatives to
that there's the voluntary search for
knowledge and that's a fine thing and
that is an antidote to this but
apart from that speaking more
practically
you tend not to learn unless you're
forced to learn and it's and what you
tend to learn by force are difficult
lessons and so people are very prone to
not
did not seek that out it's not
surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you
it's because maybe it's because they're
convinced that there's some way of
forestalling the necessary learning and
there isn't
any way of forestalling it all you do is
make it worse in the future you make
yourself smaller and you make the lesson
harder
and so that's why in So Many religious
doctrines there's emphasis on humility
you know and humility isn't to debase
yourself
it's to understand that
you don't know enough so that your life
isn't going to be miserable
and so every chance you get to grab
something new that will help you along
your way you should take it as fast as
you can but you have to have a very
tragic
I would say view of reality and also a
harsh one because it's not just tragedy
it's also malevolence you have to
understand that those are waiting for
you and that makes you desperate enough
to learn and that might be make you
desperate enough to fall out of your
ideology but
that's that's a hard way of looking at
the world
beats living through it though one of
the things I've been talking to my
audiences about is the relationship
between responsibility and meaning which
is what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying
um messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it
um
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
exaggerated by as a consequence of human
failing as a consequence of malevolence
and betrayal and self-betrayal and
deceit and all those things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the Baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and they have the reasons but
you need something to put up against
that and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the Instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right a clear
conscience is different than happiness
that's better yeah that's better
guilting yourself you're not feeling bad
about yourself that's right you feel
that you've Justified you've Justified
your existence right and so you're not
waking up at three in the morning in a
cold sweat thinking about all the
terrible things that you've involved
yourself in what you said to someone
that you shouldn't have said or how you
acted or what opportunity you lost or or
or or yeah or or the things that you've
that you've let go that you should have
capitalized on and all of that and so if
you think about the times when you're at
peace with yourself with regards to how
you're conducting yourself in the world
it's almost always conditions under
which you've adopted responsibility
right at least the most the most guilt I
think that you can experience perhaps is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and I unless you're Psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
only are you not taking care of yourself
let's say so someone else has to but
you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that you
know we kind of have this idea that
while you're free as a child and then
you
let me see if I can if I can put this
properly that you have a certain
delightful wonderful positive Freedom as
a child and then that's given up as you
approach adulthood but the truth of the
matter is is that
you have a lot of potential as a child
but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as Freedom before you
become disciplined
and discipline is a matter of the
imposition of order and the order is
necessary especially for people who are
hopeless and nihilistic and lots of
people are hopeless and nihilistic way
more people than you think and part of
that is because no one's ever really
encouraged them and so the book is in
part a matter of encouragement it's like
lay yourself lay a disciplinary
structure on yourself get the chaos in
in check and then you can move towards a
state that's Freer because it's
discipline first like look if you're
going to become a concert pianist
there's going to be several thousand
hours of extraordinarily disciplined
practice that's the imposition of order
on your potential let's say but what
comes out of that is a much grander
Freedom your best bet is truth
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick
right I mean sometimes
you go fight a dragon and it eats you
and if the if you being eaten wasn't a
real possibility it wouldn't be a real
fight
and so you see people like I've seen
people
in my clinical practice sometimes
I had one client in particular who was
undergoing a particularly vicious
divorce with someone who was really
seriously inclined to take him out and
would do pretty much everything at her
disposal to do so and I strategized with
him for about three years
and we did everything like and Hyper
carefully he was a very conscientious
and diligent person and he put into
practice everything that we discussed
and strategized and he still pretty much
he got backed into a corner so hard that
I didn't know how to help him anymore
so I would say however that he like he
was a very truthful person throughout
that and one thing he did do was
part of it was a custody battle
and he did manage despite his decline
in consequence of being repeatedly
cornered I would say he did manage to
establish what I think was a lasting
relationship with his kids
so he might have got enough out of what
he did to justify it even though the
whole landscape was pretty awful
I think that not lying is your best bet
but life is hard and people get run over
and it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to emerge in any obvious
sense triumphant
but if you take the alternative path
path especially when you're
facing severe tribulations let's say and
you complicate those with deceit you can
be sure that whatever tragedy that
you're confronting is going to turn into
not only tragedy but something very much
akin to hell
and so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering even if
you can't
overcome it or transcend it well before
the political stuff blew up I had a
million views on YouTube which is
nothing a million of anything is a lot
but then when the political Scandal
started to break yeah then people came
for them but stayed for the content and
so and that's very useful yeah well it's
fine well and it's not that surprising
well you know because of what you do
it's like people there's a great hunger
for information that is practical and
useful and that helps people find
meaning in their lives and Orient
themselves there's a great hunger for
that and most of my lectures were
derived from
solid psychology some of it experimental
some of it biological some of it from
from from the domains of Neuroscience a
lot of it from Great clinicians it's not
surprising that people find it helpful
because well great clinicians were great
because they were really helpful and so
to distill that and to offer it to
people in a digestible form to have that
have a good effect on them well that's
that's what you'd expect that's what the
whole discipline is about and so that's
been that's been great the
circumambulation that Jung talked about
was this continual we'll return to this
this continual circling in some sense of
who you could be you might notice for
example that there are themes in your
life you know when you go back across
your experiences you see you kind of
have your typical experience that sort
of repeats itself and there might be
variation on it like a musical theme but
it's it's like you're circling yourself
and getting closer to yourself as you
move across time that's the
circumambulation now you remember that
for a sec because we'll go back to it
okay so imagine that something glimmers
before you it's an interest that's
Dawning and you decide well first of all
you're paralyzed you think well how do I
know if I should pursue that it's
probably a stupid idea and the proper
response to that is you're right it
probably is a stupid idea because almost
all all ideas are stupid and so the the
probability that as you move forward on
your adventure that you're going to get
it right the first time is zero it's
just not gonna happen and so then you
might think well maybe I'll just wait
around until I get the right idea and
which people do right so they're like 40
year old 13 year olds which is not a
good idea so they wait around until it's
waiting for Godot until they finally got
it right but the problem is you're too
stupid to know when you've got it right
so waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so so you
have there's Niche called that a will to
stupidity which I really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it you know it's it's you have to take
it into account fundamentally and work
with it and so and so you can take these
tentative steps on your pathway to
Destiny and you can assume that you're
going to do it badly and that's really
useful because you don't have to beat
yourself up it's pretty easy to do it
badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all you
start your path and you think that
you're hitting you know towards your
star
and so you go in that direction and then
because
you're here the world looks a particular
way but then when you move here
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so what that means
is that now that thing that glimmers in
front of you is going to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at specifying it to begin with and
now that you're a little sharper and
more focused than you were it's it's
going to reveal itself with more
accuracy to you and so then you have to
take a
you know it's almost like 180 degree
reversal but it isn't because you know
you've
I mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far
but that's a lot farther than you would
be if you just stayed where you were
waiting
and so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot continually
because as you overshoot
even if you don't learn what you should
have done you're going to continually
learn what you shouldn't keep doing
and if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing then that's
tantamount at some point to learning at
the same time what you should be doing
so it's okay
so it's like this
now what's cool about it though I think
is that as you progress the degree of
overshooting starts to decline right and
that we know that there's nothing
hypothetical about that as you learn a
new skill like even to play play a song
on the piano for example you overshoot
madly you're making all sorts of
mistakes to begin with and then the
mistakes
foreign
they disappear the fact that you're full
of faults doesn't mean you have to stop
and thank God for that that's a really
useful thing and the fact that you're
full of faults doesn't mean that you
can't learn
and so you can positive an ideal and
you're going to be wrong about it but it
doesn't matter because what you're right
about is positing the ideal moving
towards it if the actual ideal isn't
conceptualized perfectly well first
surprise surprise because like what are
you going to do that's perfect so it
doesn't matter that it's imperfect it
just matters that you do it and that you
move forward so that's really that's
really positive news as far as I'm
concerned because you can actually do
that right you can do it badly anyone
can do that so that's that's useful I'm
incredibly nervous to uh talk in front
of you because you've got to be one of
the most formidable people that I've
ever heard of or ever listened to or
ever seen so
my question is again you're one of the
best communicators that I've ever
listened to
if I could be
half as good at you or at communicating
As You Are
I would be set how can I teach myself to
do that practice
you know really like
well there's a couple of things
to read
a lot
it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea
then not only should you read but you
should write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day
15 minutes maybe you could steal 15
minutes and do it every day
but if you do that for 10 years you
really straighten out your thinking
if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at University because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
10 times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can
specify a stepping path through it and
elaborate with the other things that you
know but to do that you have to do a lot
of reading but you also have to do a lot
of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes
so that's on the input side and then on
the output side well there's some tricks
techniques let's say is like if you're
speaking in front of a group you are not
delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when I talk to a
group I always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier too
because you know how to talk to a person
it's like can you talk to a thousand
people well probably not because it's
too intimidating but there isn't a
thousand people there there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell if they're
engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep in
which case you look at someone else
and they give you feedback about how
you're doing and so one thing is to to
have something to say yeah but the next
thing is pay attention to who you're
talking to Because unless you're very
badly socialized then that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know and well I mean I don't
know you very well but in first but on
First Sight you know you're you're doing
fine so the probability that if you pay
attention to the individuals that you're
talking to that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high and so you
don't deliver a talk to an audience
that's a really bad way of thinking
about you're actually engaged in a
conversation with an audience even if
they're not talking they're nodding and
shifting position and you know looking
like this or and you can you can pull
all that in and and use it to govern the
level at which you're addressing the
entire audience
so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could buttress that to some degree
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent
in everything you do than to learn how
to communicate I don't care if you're
going to be a carpenter I mean being a
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good Carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so the and this is something that the
liberal arts colleges I think I don't
know if they've forgotten it but they
don't do a very good job of marketing
it's like what's the use of a bachelor's
degree a Bachelor of Arts it's like well
you can think you can write you can
speak you've read something
it's like
the economic value of that is
incalculable the people that I've
watched in my life have been
spectacularly successful are they have
skills
clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're six it doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're a really good negotiator
everybody walks away from the
negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice oh yes chapter nine is assume
that the person you are listening to
might know something you don't
this is a chapter about conversation and
about the different forms conversation
takes
and it's a chapter about humility
and it's a chapter about listening and
the humility element is it took me a
long time to understand why there's
religious injunctions supporting
humility
to even understand what the word really
meant in that sort of technical sense
and it means something like this it
means what you don't know is more
important than what you know
and that's a lovely thing to then then
what you don't know can start to be your
friend you see people are very defensive
about what they know and for the reasons
we've already discussed but the thing is
you don't know enough and the re you can
tell you don't know enough because your
life is not what it could be and neither
is the life of the people around you you
just don't know enough and so what that
means is that every time you encounter
some evidence that you're ignorant
someone points it out you should be
happy about that because you think oh
you just told me how I'm wrong it's like
great like maybe I had to sift through a
lot of nonsense to get through the real
message that you're telling me but if
you could actually tell me some way that
I'm wrong and then maybe give me a hint
about how to not be wrong like that well
then I wouldn't have to be wrong like
that anymore that that would be a good
thing and you can you can you can embark
on that Adventure by listening to people
and if you listen to people they will
tell you
they'll tell you amazing things if you
listen to them and many of those things
are little tools that you can put in
your toolkit like Batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often and so the
humility element is well
do you want to be right
or do you want to be learning
and then it's deeper than that it's do
you want to be the the tyrannical King
who's already got everything figured out
or do you want to be the continually
transforming hero or fool for that
matter who's getting better all the time
and that's actually a choice you know
it's a deep choice and it's better to be
the self-transforming fool who's humble
enough to make friends with what he or
she doesn't know and to listen when
people talk and listening is a
transformative exercise like if if you
listen to the people in your life for
example if you actually listen to them
they'll tell you what's wrong with them
and how to fix it and what they want
they can't even help it if you start
listening because people are so shocked
if you actually listen to them that they
they tell you all those sorts of things
that they might not have even intended
to things they don't even know and then
you can you can work with that but our
topic is
the rising tide of compelled speech in
Canada
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
go
where is security
that's pure narcissism at work by the
way
[Applause]
you don't want to hijack to hijack an
event like this
that other people put time and effort
into and to use they their their
civility of the crowd and the civility
of the organizers as an excuse to
blatantly yell out your ill-informed
opinions is no way to conduct a civil
dialogue these people
are not your friends
and we say you know
that's that that and mark my words
that's the sounds of the barbarians
pounding at the gates right
yeah that's I'll I'll tell you again too
that Yusuf
in Kuwait
[Music]
what would you call it in Kuwait
sensation is the best formulation of
their argument
and there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you
so keep that in mind
it's not amusing there's nothing to it
there's nothing for it the thing that's
also quite appalling is that there's no
evidence whatsoever that the people who
are conducting these protests know what
it is that they're protesting against
you know I was in
[Applause]
I I was in the midst of a discussion
attempting to make the case that
it's freedom of speech that's that is
what people who have nothing still have
right so if you look at the tyrannical
structure of our society let's say the
people at the top have access to means
of communication everyone knows that
it's the people at the bottom who have
the right to say what they think however
badly they say it that enables them to
get a Toe Hold into the system and to
and to make their suffering known that's
what freedom of speech is for and so
like what's the protest against that and
I'll tell you you know that the radical
neo-marxis types they speak the language
of power and that's what they're
speaking right now and if you want to
live in a world where everyone speaks
the language of power then just let them
do what they're doing and see what
happens I wouldn't recommend it it's not
a pretty Road and you're all in a
position you're on a situation in your
life now where you have to make
decisions about these sorts of things
like is this the sort of institution
that you want this to be I do believe
it's the case because I've watched
people do very difficult things like
people who work in palliative care
Awards so all they're ever dealing with
is pain and death right and they can do
it they get up in the morning they go to
work and they take care of those people
they lose people on a weekly basis and
yet they can do it and what that shows
is that if you turn around and you
confront the suffering voluntarily you
find out that you are way tougher than
you think it's not that life is better
than you think life is as harsh as you
think it might even be worse but you are
way tougher than you think if you turn
around and confront it and so then what
you discover is that there's a spirit
within you that pursues that can pursue
something meaningful that has the
resilience and the strength to contend
properly with the catastrophe of
existence without becoming bitter that's
actually the central so and then I would
say that's one of the central themes of
12 rules for life is that make no
mistake about it like the first Noble
Truth of Buddhism life is suffering this
is true and it's worse than that because
it's suffering contaminated by
malevolence that's the Baseline but and
so that's very pessimistic but the
optimistic part is that you are so tough
if you can actually not only deal with
that you can improve it it's like oh
well that's a horrible situation but it
turns out that I'm armed for the task
well that's that's a great thing for
people to know and I do believe I think
the fact that we're armed for the task
is even more true than the fact that
life is catastrophe contaminated by
malevolence we're stronger than things
are terrible so and things are pretty
terrible so that means we're pretty damn
strong wow yes it's a very good thing to
know and it's not naive optimism it's a
very different thing it's like no things
are terrible they're brutal and you are
so tough you can't believe it you love
to quote this line This Nietzsche line
that all anyone who has a why to live
for can endure almost any how yep what's
your why what is driving you you see
when people read history they they
either read it as a detached Observer or
they tend to read it as
well maybe the heroic the heroic
protagonist people like to imagine that
they would be Schindler in Schindler's
List but that's wrong
so because the probability that you'll
be the perpetrator is much higher
especially merely the perpetrator who's
in constant silence when silence is not
the appropriate thing
so I wanted to having figured out what
constituted hell and the pathway to that
which would be
I suppose the cowardice that produces
the cowardice and resentment that
produces either complicitness in those
events or failure to oppose them when
they emerge I wanted to understand what
the opposite of that was
because I think that's what needs to be
learned from what happened in the 20th
century and so that's why I wrote maps
of meaning was to understand that and to
lay out what the opposite was
and then that turned out to be extremely
helpful to me and then to the people I
started to teach about that because
it's useful to know what the opposite of
hell is
and I've been teaching those things to
people since 1993 so that's 25 years and
the response from the students has
always been the same sort of response
that I'm getting now
absence some of the negative
characterizations let's say which which
have emerged for particular reasons but
the students have always said one of two
things
and and this is the vast majority of
them this isn't cherry-picked responses
it's been the same everywhere
um
they tell me and this is the same
response I get from my audiences now too
is they say you've given me words to
explain things to explain and understand
things that I always knew to be true
or
I was in a very dark place for one of
the seven reasons that people might be
in a dark place alcohol or drugs or
failure of relationships or lack of
vision or nihilism or or hopelessness or
depression or anxiety or you know all
the pitfalls that people can encounter
and I've been developing a vision for my
life and trying to adopt responsibility
and trying to be careful with what I say
and things are way better
and that's what drives me what's your
definition of greatness
[Music]
well greatness is what reveals itself
when you
when you attempt to formulate when you
attempt to carefully articulate and live
out what you believe to be true
it just happens because there isn't
anything more powerful than truth
right that's the antidote to suffering
truth
right so it's a strange thing because
you think well yeah it produces a lot of
suffering too it's like yeah in the
short term they say Do you believe in
god let's say and my response to that
always is well I don't know what you
mean when you ask me that question so I
don't know how to answer it I don't know
what you mean by believe but I can tell
you something that I believe and I would
say this is a way of speaking
symbolically
I do believe so I was thinking the other
day a week ago I was thinking about this
this little fantasy that entered my mind
I was thinking about St Joseph's
oratorio in Montreal and Saint Joseph's
oratorio is a very large religious
building it's one of the biggest
cathedral-like structures in the world
and it's set on the hill on Mount Royal
and it's set up where it can catch the
sun you know so it's an image of the
Heavenly City on the hill right it's an
image of the structures that we strive
to create that's what it is independent
of its specifically Christian or
religious function that's what it stands
for symbolically okay so it's the city
on the hill it's it's what we're
striving towards when we walk uphill in
life okay now the way the the oratorio
is structured there's hundreds of steps
leading to it up front and in the early
part of the 20th century a lot of people
who had physical disabilities came there
and they struggled up the step on their
crutches and many of them left their
crutches in the oratorio you can see
hundreds of them if you go there it's
quite an interesting site and I was
thinking about that and I was thinking
about what that meant and this is what
it means it means that
you know everyone has their disabilities
let's say and I know that some people
are far more terribly affected than
other people I'm perfectly aware of that
but the question is what do you do about
that and what you do is you you set
yourself up on your crutches and you
struggle up the bloody Hill that's what
you do and you struggle up the hill
towards the kingdom of God that's what
you do because the alternative is to
descend into the abyss that's the
alternative and then so to say well do
you believe it's like I believe that you
should struggle uphill towards the city
of God on your crutches
that's what you should do
that's the opposite of the descent into
the abyss
and so that's that's at the foundation
of our civilization that idea well argue
with it if you will see if you can
figure out why that's not an acceptable
idea maybe you should help someone
struggle up the hill perhaps you should
you know you can lend a hand to someone
although you don't want to take the
burden away from them entirely because
there's something Noble about struggling
up the hill right there's something
that's Adventure that's the call to
proper being it's like well we don't
need to forget this
you know we don't need to forget it the
universities have been there since time
immemorial to try to push that idea
forward through the generations and
everyone needs to know that idea that's
what gives your life not happiness
forget about that
if it comes well great accept it I made
a decision when the computers started to
become omnipresent and so that would
have been about 1993 that I was going to
spend a year and that was the first year
that I was teaching in Boston pretty
much doing nothing but figuring out how
Intel 486 has worked and it meant there
was a lot of other things that I had to
put on hold but I did become a competent
computer user and I was I'm pretty fast
but you know my son it's just annoying
as hell to watch him on the computer and
on the phone because and my graduate
students as well because they're so much
faster than me that it's not even funny
and I'm not really accustomed to being
slower than someone else in the room you
know if I had children now the one thing
I would bloody well make sure that they
knew was how to use a computer how to
program man because if you're smart and
you can use a computer you are so much
smarter than you are if you're just
smart that it's not even funny you know
and you talk to people you see this in
Silicon Valley all the time you talk to
people who are expert computer users
they are so bloody powerful it is just
beyond belief so and that that's going
to do nothing but expand right because
Moore's Law is not dead and computers
are doubling in power every 18 months
and and so and who the hell knows where
that's going to go I don't know what
what percentage of human effort is spent
in counterproductive activity you know I
I'm I'm not an absolute cynic about that
but I mean when I talk to undergraduates
I ask them you know how much time do you
waste every day by your own
Reckoning and it's somewhere between
five and eight hours you know it's a lot
of it's a lot of time well I usually
walk through I walk the students through
an economic analysis of that I said well
you know why don't you value your time
at fifty dollars an hour and calculate
for yourself just exactly what you're
doing to your future by your inability
to discipline yourself it's worth
thinking through
in any case people do waste a lot of
time and they are they also act
counterproductively a lot of the time
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious industrious is
discipline yourself and so what do you
do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time I would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because I've
got more and more disciplined like get
up early in the morning and get your
things done man learn to get up at six
in the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your day done by
the time other people haul their sorry
asses out of bed and so that's a massive
massive Advantage look Will Ferrell
Warren Farrell not the comedian Warren
Farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book I
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 13 longer hours you make
forty percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them Works an extra 10 percent
it's not much well how often is that
person going to be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss it's like you're going to look at
the 10 people and you're going to think
oh that guy's always here like 45
minutes early it's like why don't we
give him the promotion obviously right
so these tie these small edges that you
can manage like that work an extra 10
extra 13 percent have non-proportional
payoffs that's part of the Pareto
distribution so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses I'm too tired in the morning
I don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
Google Calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at Bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also helps you plan what you
want to do so I could say well layout
your calendar
and design the days you would like to
have that's what your calendars have is
for so you can put in all sorts of
things in there you want to do and that
would be good for you and that's a
really good a really good way to start
being more industrious make a plan you
need a plan for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour all of that all of that I make
lists constantly of what I have to do
and they're like daily weekly monthly
yearly right now I can't look out more
than about six months you know because
my life is too complicated and chaotic
but but you need a vision of who you
could be what character you could have
three to five years out you can't go
much farther than that because life is
too unpredictable I think to make Vision
that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too too much chance associated
with it to spend a lot of time on maybe
you can stretch it to five years and in
rare cases you can have a 10-year goal
but it has to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down and what because what are
you going to do you're going to stumble
around and get get what you need you're
going to stumble around and be useful to
other people and it's useful to be
useful to other people you know they
want to work with you then they want to
do things with you they want to have you
around they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a bit that's hell that's
a bad outcome because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want another amazing
Jordan Peterson video check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there